je ne suis en aucun cas malades gg 1
j'ai un syndrome autistique qui est ma
force au quotidien mais qui est aussi ma
faiblesse je ne suis pas perpétuellement
atteints de maladies incurables que ça
serait une maladie psychique ou une
maladie physique non
[Musique]
je ne dis pas que ça ne pourrit pas le
quotidien qu'on n'a pas l'air de malades
quand on on est en colère qu'on est
énervé mais de manière 10 fois plus
forte que tout un chacun
on a l'air malade pour les autres moi
même des fois je me dis mais je suis
j'ai l'esprit malade je ne me sens pas
bien mais c'est pas une maladie à
proprement parler et c'est ça que je
veux dire le syndrome d'asperger guerre
c'est comme son nom l'indiqué un
troubles envahissants du développement
qui fait partie de l'autisme de
l'échelle de l'autisme du spectre de
l'autisme et c'est un syndrome les
géants nautisme l'egypte les troubles
cognitifs très important c'est surtout
le syndrome de cannes rca 2 le la partie
assez aggravante de l'autisme ou si
c'est d'ailleurs ce syndrome là que les
gens connaissent le plus sans savoir le
nom il pense que l'autisme
justement c'est un cliché pense que
l'autisme c'est uniquement ces gens là
qui sont des pressions permanence qui ne
s'exprime pas ou par bribes ou par ou
par mots quelconque qui se tape la tête
quand ils sont pas bien voilà qui
s'expriment comme chewbacca on va dire
[Musique]
dans l'autisme à supérieur il ya ce
qu'on appelle le met vraiment au sommet
il ya le syndrome du savant par exemple
kim peek qui a donné ses traits à rennes
mène dans le film de 88 avec dustin
hoffman et tom cruise était quelqu'un
d'assez incroyable qui savait lire deux
pages simultanément mais c'est pas la
réalité de l'autisme ça c'est des gens
qui sortent des sentiers de l'autisme
s'ils sont un peu ils ont leur leur
petit ils ont leurs petites branches
dans le spectre de l'autisme leur kit
branche qui est autisme savant mais ils
sont que quelques-uns il y en a pas
beaucoup
on pourrait penser que je suis à la
limite entre un autiste de haut niveau
un outil ce savant mais je ne suis pas
autiste avant et je suis autiste de haut
niveau certes tous les outils sas
période sur pas des autistes de haut
niveau mais moi je suis père mnésiques
donc je me souviens d'énormément de
choses et je dois prendre conscience des
facilités que je peux avoir dans
certains domaines même s'il ya des côtés
son qui est de se souvenir de choses
qu'on aimerait totalement oublié mais
qu'on ne parvient pas et qui nous dit la
santé évidemment
[Musique]
on est pris un peu pour des gens un peu
psychorigide un peu fou
qui ça donne uniquement une activité
puis le reste n'a plus d'importance pour
eux qui sont implémentés d'empathie
aussi on dit souvent ça mais la majorité
des gens etc autistes dont moi on est
seul on est seul malgré nous on n'a plus
envie d'être seul on a une solitude
forcée une solitude malsaine
malheureusement on a beaucoup de mal à
enclencher une conversion ce qui fait
qu'on reste en perpétuellement seul on
se dit allez on bouge on y va et on n'y
arrive pas et les gens ils nous aident
pas parce qu'ils viennent pas nous voir
moi je demande que ça qu'on vient de me
parler qu'on crée des amitiés des
affinités qu'on fasse des sorties qu'on
aille au musée qu'on aille visiter
je pense que l'autisme mérite un bon
mode d'emploi pour les neurotypiques qui
ne comprennent pas qu'il ya des fois on
n'a pas envie d'être accompagné on va le
faire savoir directement ou
indirectement on n'aura plus envie
d'être accompagné on en aura marre il y
aura eu trop de relations sociales
on a envie d'être seul et ça c'est une
solitude scène on va dire si une
solitude qu'on a besoin qu'on a demandé
le plus important pour un sujet
supérieure 7 entrons en bien entouré
entouré de personnes qui te comprennent
qu'ils font des efforts pour t'aider et
pourtant
et pour te guider à travers ce flou ce
noir continue qui est la société humaine
c'est pas quelque chose d'évident à
comprendre et et s'il ya des gens pour
les accompagner des neuro type et qui
est re comprennent la société mieux que
nous et qui seront à même de nous
l'expliquer on avancera du bon côté